[Música]
los seres humanos están por todas partes
con asentamientos en todos los
continentes y presentes en los rincones
más aislados de las junglas océanos y
tundras de la tierra nuestro impacto es
tan profundo que la mayoría de
científicos opina que la huella de la
humanidad en la historia geológica
terrestre es indeleble qué ocurriría si
de pronto desaparecieran todos los
humanos
sin nadie para mantenerlas muchas
creaciones enseguida darían problemas
horas después de nuestra desaparición
las refinerías de petróleo fallarían y
producirían incendios de un mes en
Plantas como las del Oeste de la India
el sur de los Estados Unidos y Corea del
Sur en los sistemas de metro como el de
Londres
Moscú o la ciudad de Nueva York se
abandonarían cientos de bombas de
drenaje que inundarían los túneles en
tres días
al final de la primera semana la mayoría
de los generadores de emergencia se
apagarían y una vez extinguidos los
incendios la tierra quedaría oscuras por
primera vez en siglos tras el
catastrófico primer mes los cambios
serían más graduales en 20 años las
aceras se agrietarían a causa de malezas
y raíces al mismo tiempo los túneles
inundados
erosionarían las calles y las
convertirían en ríos en climas templados
las aguas se congelarían y
descongelarían lo cual agrietaría el
pavimento y el hormigón
las tuberías que gotean causarían el
mismo efecto en los edificios de cemento
y pasados 200 inviernos la mayoría de
los rascacielos se inclinarían y se
derrumbarían en ciudades situadas en
deltas fluviales como Houston estos
edificios serían barridos totalmente y
llenarían Los afluentes cercanos con
cemento triturado
las áreas suburbanas y Rurales se
deteriorarían más lentamente pero de
manera sorprendentes fugas mo plagas de
insectos y roedores todas ellas enemigos
comunes de propietarios de inmuebles
ahora estarían a sus anchas en 75 años
la mayoría de los Pilares de las
viviendas estarían podridos y hundidos y
el montón de escombros resultantes sería
hogar de lagartijas y roedores en este
mundo poso humano local tendría un nuevo
significado las ciudades estarían llenas
de plantas importadas que crecerían sin
control en sus hogares de acogida los
jacintos de agua cubrirían las aguas de
Shanghai como una gruesa alfombra verde
el venenoso heraclium gigante invadiría
las orillas del río támesis de Londres
los aislantos chinos crecerían frondosos
en las calles de Nueva York los
rascacielos derrumbados aportarían
cemento triturado al suelo del Bosque
cuya acidez se desplomaría lo que
permitiría que una nueva Flora prospere
esta diversidad Pos humana se extendería
al reino animal
los animales explorarían las plantas
nuevas y viejas y se adentrarían en
nuevos hábitats con la ayuda de los
restos de puentes
nuestras infraestructuras salvarían a
unos animales y condenarían a otros las
cucarachas seguirían prosperando en su
hábitat Tropical original pero sin los
sistemas de calefacción sus primas de la
ciudad Se congelarían y se extinguirían
pronto
la mayoría de los animales domesticados
no sobrevivirían sin nosotros salvo un
puñado de cerdos perros y gatos
callejeros en cambio la menor
contaminación lumínica salvaría a unos
mil millones de pájaros al año cuyas
migraciones estaban interrumpidas por
las luces de las torres de comunicación
y los cables de alta tensión los
mosquitos se multiplicarían sin fin en
una de sus cunas humanas favoritas los
neumáticos que duran como mínimo unos
mil años mientras la fauna y la flora
prosperarían el clima de la tierra se
recuperaría de miles de años de impacto
del hombre
en 35.000 años el ciclo de las plantas
eliminaría los últimos restos de plomo
en el suelo de la tierra y podrían
necesitarse hasta 65,000 años más para
que los niveles de CO2 volviesen a
niveles pre humanos
incluso pasados varios millones de años
el legado de la humanidad persistiría
tallado en granito inmutable el monte
rushmore sobreviviría durante 7,2
millones de años la composición química
de nuestras esculturas de bronce las
mantendría reconocibles durante 10
millones de años y enterrados en las
profundidades los restos de las ciudades
se conservarían en el tiempo como un
tipo de tecnofósiles al final esos
restos también serán barridos de la
superficie del planeta la humanidad no
siempre ha estado aquí y no lo hará
Eternamente pero investigar el mundo sin
nosotros quizá nos permita aprender más
sobre el mundo en el que vivimos ahora
tenemos las herramientas y el
conocimiento para salvar el mundo Pero
cuál es el siguiente paso visite
et.t.com/lineada Earth School para
obtener una hoja de ruta que puede
seguir y medidas concretas que puede
tomar para marcar la diferencia